i got these two great tennis players
all we need
is a club
everything to go from prodigy to pro
race your hand sabrina venus williams
but you think
nobody's taking that bat
tennis takes expert instruction
it takes families with unlimited
financial resources
it's like asking somebody to believe
that you got the next two mozarts in
your house
venus and serena gonna shake up this
the sky world that's it there you go
they're not going to wimbledon like this
not with you and me on those raggedy
courts
we just got to stick to the plan we got
champions in another room
you called
richard i'm impressed i think you might
just have the next michael jordan
oh no brother man i gots me the next two
me ask you about something what do you
want out of this i know what your dad
wants but what about you well i went to
winton as many times as anyone's ever
wanted you think you can do that
every american player got good following
this path we gonna do this a different
way
you pulled them out of juniors now you
pull them out of practice you do it
constantly i'm trying to look out for my
kids you're looking out for yourself
this is their life
you've got to let them decide
venus williams
what you want let's show all those
people that i can handle what's
[Music]
you are a coming
and the whole world knows
she's playing the best player on the
planet she can't beat her
but what if she do
ain't nobody
i have never been more proud
in my whole life
you wanna show them how dangerous you
are
let me see your dangerous face
that's your dangerous [ __ ] make some
dangerous noises
that's your dangerous face
okay don't do that for the people
you